away from Chick-fil-A which shows you
that Dei wokeness it's all just really
the conclusion of liberalism
it's everywhere it's everywhere it's
even in your religious chicken sandwich
and it's especially at Disney there is a
fairly disturbing video came out of
Disneyland
out of the enchanted chamber princess
Boutique
and it is of a pretty little princess
with a mustache
it's a dude dressed up
as a princess and he's not one of the
enthusiasts he is one of the workers
there
employed by Disney take a look take a
look or listen if you're thriving in
your car my name's Nick I want to figure
out another apprentices I'm here to shop
you around and make all your selections
for the day to a little girl he's got
lots of eye shadow on and just a big
bushy mustache
trying to sell extremely overpriced
dresses for little girls to those poor
poor parents who are going to have to
Shell out a ton of money
okay
what's wrong with this scene the
mustache is a problem yeah the fact that
it's an obvious dude wearing a dress
that's a problem the bigger problem
though is
who this is for
it's not even just that Disney World is
for kids and so this weird sexual stuff
has no place in front of kids
it's even more than the question of kids
or minors or what's appropriate for
certain ages it's a question of
who are these people serving what is the
point of Disney World what is the point
of any of these companies
is it about the customer or is it about
the fantasies of the employee we used to
have a saying In America which is that
the customer is always right
now the customer doesn't seem to matter
at all customer doesn't matter at all
with Bud Light and transheiser Bush
customer doesn't matter at all with
Target customer doesn't even matter at
Disney World in Disneyland
who is this for when I was a young man
I was young coming up in Show Business
and I'd sometimes take these service
industry jobs
one of which I was hired to be a fake
sommelier at a wedding the wedding was
actually for George Soros it's a story
for another time but I remember we were
all there was the Caterers and the
sommelier and all these people and the
guy who was running the event he said
hey what is this about what are we all
here for and in my mind I thought I
don't know we're here to make a quick
buck and then go back to our regular
lives but no he said no what this is all
about what this is for is service
your job here is to serve the customer
especially if you're in the service
industry
but increasingly in our economy and in
our whole culture
it's not about the customer it's not
about the people we're supposed to serve
it's somehow the other way around
little kids don't go to Disneyland so
that they can affirm some deviant man's
delusions
parents don't spend an arm and a leg to
take their kids to Disneyland so that
their kids can be exposed to a Mustachio
to strange fellow living at his fantasy
of being a pretty princess
okay if you want to take the job as a
pretty princess
you definitely have to shave the
mustache and you got to be a chick
because it's not about you and
princesses or chicks and you're not so
you've got to put your fantasies aside
especially when we're talking about a
place like Disneyland which is supposed
to indulge the fantasies of little
children who for whom it is appropriate
to have little fantasies and play act
them out sometimes for adults it's not
appropriate to do that
one of the the big cases to enshrine
transgenderism in our law was a the
Harris Funeral Home case and the Harris
Funeral Home case before The Supreme
Court
raised a question of do employees have
an obligation to follow the rules
sometimes for the benefit of their
customers there's this Funeral Home
Harris Funeral Homes and one of the
employees at the funeral home was a dude
who thought he was a chick and so one
day he decided he was going to wear
little skirts and put on lipstick and go
in and do his job and the owner of the
funeral home said hey man I I don't know
what's going on with you obviously you
got some issues but
we've got to be respectful to our
customers when people come to the
funeral home they're grieving they're in
a very vulnerable state they don't need
distractions they don't need to deal
with some weird political ideology
they're trying to grieve their dead
loved ones and so it's not about you
it's about them
and this strange fellow decided no it's
actually all about me any suit him and
he ended up winning the case now that's
enshrined in law we're not going to have
a good Society if we invert that order
are we around here to serve others in
accordance with reason and the truth or
do we just view everybody in the world
including poor little kids including
their parents who spend a lot of money
to take him to Disneyland do we just
view them merely as instruments to serve
us and our deviant desires two totally
different societies by the way when you
want to satiate your appetites and
desires the best way to do it is
obviously with good ranchers right now
head on over to goodranchers.com use
promo code Knowles this Father's Day let
your dad unleash his inner Grill Master
whether he prefers a sizzling steak or
savory grilled chicken look no further
than the gift of meat from our friends
at good ranchers good ranchers offers
Ribeyes New York strips T-Bones all
natural burgers and the most delicious
chicken you could ever want plus right
now you will get thirty three zero
dollars off with our code Knowles at
goodranchers.com good ranchers also
offers a price lock guarantee for the
next two years which is completely
insane imagine if you could have locked
in your price two years ago you would
have saved hundreds of dollars not sure
how to grill the perfect steak well
they've got tons of recipes on their
website like uh one of our great
favorites how to cook a steak better
than Gordon Ramsay whether your dad is a
steak lover a barbecue Enthusiast or
just enjoys a good old-fashioned Burger
good Rancher says the best burgers in a
business by the way unbelievable steaks
too but the burgers are making me
salivate thinking about them you got to
order today make this Father's Day a
success go to goodranchors.com use code
knowleskin wels for 30 off any box promo
code Knowles at goodranters.com good
ranchers American Meat delivered right
now go to puretalk.com slash Knowles
we're all trying to improve the country
here aren't we and therefore we've got
to be a little bit Discerning about the
partners that we choose to work with in
one company I'm very very proud to stand
behind and a company that's very proud
to stand behind us and our country is
pure talk veteran owned with a 100
American Workforce they share our
beliefs our desires for this country
that is why Pure Talk is the official
cell phone wireless partner of the daily
wire but that's not the only reason Pure
Talk also happens to be the most
Dependable 5G Network in the United
States they've got a top tier service at
a fraction of the cost of those other
woke companies you know the ones I'm
talking about ATT Verizon T-Mobile those
companies that don't care about you or
your values in fact you can get
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
with a mobile hotspot for just 55 a
month you vote with how you spend your
money so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you instead
go to puretalk.com Knowles you will get
great coverage and save while you're
doing it go to puretalk.com Knowles save
an additional fifty five zero percent
off your first month because they
actually care about you go to
puretalk.com wireless for Americans buy
Americans
you see this kind of Madness especially
in higher education
there was a law school commencement
ceremony at CUNY
that featured a speaker sometimes these
commencements have student speakers and
the student speakers are usually kind of
Goody Two-Shoes types but increasingly
they can be left-wing activists who are
speaking out on behalf of the student
body and one such speech came from
Fatima Muhammad student speaker for CUNY
law school and Fatima Muhammad made all
sorts of claims she is a pro-palestine
activist she really doesn't like Israel
not a huge fan of a certain ancient
nomadic tribe of people and so she makes
her comments about that but she's
broadly against the West she's against
white people and patriarchy and that is
how her speech is being reported
pro-palestine student goes off on the
Jews or left-wing student goes off on
white supremacy and the patriarchy but
there's something even more Insidious
about this girl's law school speech see
if you can pick it up
I'm here to celebrate who and what we
are who you are like many of you I chose
CUNY school of law for its articulated
mission to be law in the service of
human needs one of very few legal
institutions created
to recognize that the law is a
manifestation of white supremacy that
continues to oppress and suppress people
in this nation and around the world we
joined this institution to be equipped
with the necessary legal skills to
protect our communities to protect the
organizers fighting endlessly day in and
out with no accolades No cameras no
votes no PhD grants working to lift the
facade of legal neutrality and confront
the systems of Oppression that wreck
violence on them
the craziest thing about this speech is
not that the pro-palestine girl hates
the Jews the craziest thing about this
speech is not that the leftist girl
hates the white people and the Man in
the patriarchy and all the rest it's
that sentence right at the top where she
says CUNY recognizes that the law
is just a facade to uphold white
supremacy the craziest thing she says in
Her speech
is about the law
because this girl graduated from law
school she was selected to be the
speaker at her law school graduation she
doesn't know what the law is
she doesn't believe in the law
the law at its most basic level is an
ordinance of reason for the common good
by the one who has care of the community
and promulgated that's the the
description of the law the definition
that Saint Thomas Aquinas gives it's a
really basic very good one
a related concept is justice justice is
a habit a virtue that inclines the will
to render to each and to all what he
deserves
again really basic definition of justice
what this girl says at her law school
graduation is oh the law Justice that's
all Bs
the law it's fake the law is totally
fake thank you for giving me my law
degree the law is totally fake it is not
an ordinance of reason it is not for the
common good it's nothing more than a
bunch of gobbledygook that we use to
enshrine the tyranny of will of of the
willfulness of one group which is the
white people or the Jews or whoever
she's going off on people that I hate
and so what we do when we go to law
school is we just get a credential that
allows us to wield this deceptive
instrument for our own tyranny of will
to to give ourselves more power and to
dominate the groups the white people and
the Jews and the men and whoever that we
hate
that's what she's saying that's the not
so subtle subtext of all of it she's
saying the law is not
objective the law is not just the law is
not real the law does not derive from
anything outside of our own desires
that's the state of higher education
that's the state of the law that's the
state of Justice in America
if our next generation of lawyers
of the people who are supposed to be
running the show in the political order
does not believe in law then we're going
to have lawlessness and I'll tell you
what
if this lady doesn't like what America
looks like with Law and Order just wait
until she sees America without Law and
Order
because yes the the positive law the
civil law is sometimes an imperfect
reflection of the natural law and the
background principles of justice that
that exist even outside of our own
personal experience and desire yeah
that's true yes it's true that the
system of justice is imperfect and
sometimes innocent people go to jail and
sometimes guilty people get off the hook
and yeah that's all true
but if you if you think a law-abiding
America is bad just wait until you see a
Lawless America this is how I feel about
attacks on Christian nationalism
Christian religious right
people say I hate the religious right of
man you think the religious right is bad
just wait until you see that you're
religious right or the irreligious left
though I suppose that's a redundant
phrase
oh you think Christian nationalism is
bad just wait until you see unchristian
nationalism
[Music]
that because that's going to be a lot
worse
a society where even the people who
graduate with the law degrees don't
think there's anything objective here
boy that was a great clip make sure you
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time